and once we get a game
accepted on leeches then we will
we'll switch back to lee jess
wow
all right
well that was convenient timing
um
okay great push and baby good luck okay
we've got a double king's pawn game here
all right very nice a lot of options for
white here we could see an italian game
i'm expecting the royal lopez yeah you
should always expect the royal lopez in
slow time controls
so we'll play a6 no problem
can i play you on the chess
well
maybe after this game
maybe maybe we can play after this game
you guys can be next on the list
okay so knight f6
knight f6 is the main move here
and then castles
bishop e7
push him baby
strong
uh a strong rapid and classical player
placing
going for scholars isn't good for
classical
i would say probably not
most of the time going for a scholars
mate is probably not going to be
a super strong plan
even in the faster time controls
so we're not gonna get a marshall
no marshall
this time but we see d3 which means
we're we're probably gonna get some more
positional type game though i will say
that i don't think this move is
particularly the most accurate
because i think generally white wants to
try to play d4 in one move
okay
but
this pawn is now
it's now being threatened
so we'll start with b5
d3 i like c32 i like c3
yeah anytime i see i see e4 e5
uh
i'm basically expecting aurora lopez
i'm expecting a real lopez
because it's i think it's the strongest
opening
or at the level that i'm at
it's one of the most solid choices
if i see anything else i'm very happy to
play against anything else because um
i don't think
i don't think many other openings are
really super testing in classical chess
other than the royal lopez let's start
with e45
like italian game i'm very confident
about facing in classical chess and
especially stuff like the ponziani and
king's gambit i'm like
very very confident in facing those in
classical chess
so the rural lopez is what i expect
white to play
it's the strongest line you should
expect your opponent to play
the strongest lines
scotch
yeah scotch and four knights they are
they're not bad either they're not bad
okay
let's try to focus on the game
this is 30 plus 20 so we've got a lot of
time i think we want to play bishop c5
and if he plays bishop e3 then we can
play d6
right
i think right now he might even be
threatening to play knight g5
so how about this what if we play bishop
c5 if he plays bishop g5
then this pin might be a little bit
annoying but we have not committed d6
yet
so
we may be able to drop it back but i
don't know if that would be a waste of
time
so right now i'm debating should we play
bishop e7 or bishop c5
and i'm sure there's a correct
theoretical answer like i'm i'm sure
this question has been asked before
and unfortunately i don't actually know
the answer
i don't actually know the
answer here
i i feel like this is a very strong
diagonal
and
okay
i'm going to play bishop c5
and if he plays bishop g5
then i i don't know if i am
okay he does play bishop g5 we could
start with h6 bishop takes f2 and knight
g54
it doesn't actually work because the
bishop is defended from the knight
but also i will ask
not to suggest moves
please don't suggest
moves um
just because if i didn't see that or if
that worked and i didn't see it then
uh that wouldn't be very
good
am i grandmaster from may chess i'm not
a grandmaster
i'm not a grandmaster but maybe one day
i will become a grandmaster so
what i'm debating is
do i really
like
can i take with the pawn and then just
attack on the g file
so i'm trying to figure out
and like castle queen side
d6 bishop e6
queen d7 castle's queen side and then
you know like take with the pawn
if i play knight e7
well if i play it right away i hang my
pawn
so let's start with d6
and i think we've got
a nice plane here we'll play h6 and then
we'll play 97
with the idea of coming to knight g6
okay
okay this is classical there's no reason
to be
moving this quickly h6 what if he plays
d4
well i can take he'll take
and i'll take
and that position looks very good for me
uh well actually he does have this
tactic which is
takes takes
and queen d5 check in that line and that
wins back the piece
or wins back the pawn actually just wins
back the pawn
um
i can't even really play rook f8 king g8
in the end because
if i play rook f8 my pawn on h7 hangs
so that's kind of unfortunate
h6
i feel like d4
d4
is very unlikely to be a good move
though
although
we might
back up with the bishop just so that
so why
97 takes takes
d4 takes takes
ooh
yeah so we probably
we probably will not take that if he
goes d4
in that case
97 d4
bishop b6
but then we're just losing a pawn
okay
so
let's start with
h6
and we're not expecting him to take okay
he
backs up very very quickly
as he should
i think bishop h4 is very clearly the
best move here
bishop b6
if he plays d4
i could also play pawn to g5
i could play that move
like uh
bishop b6
d4
g5
takes
maybe i should develop this bishop first
bishop b7
get pressure along this diagonal
bishop d5 may be
annoying in some of these lines
i think i'll start with bishop b7
we have some potential of playing g5
later
he definitely has the option to sack but
i don't know 97 knight g6 is the other
idea
could all be prepping he's gaining time
that's true we're not actually that deep
into the game this could still be part
of his prep
i would be slightly surprised though
considering the amount of
time he's spent um on some of his
he has spent some amount of time right
yo joe bruno stl what's up man
how am i not snowed in
well maybe i would be snowed in if i
lived in st louis
but i am
not actually
living in st louis right now
okay so he plays a4 he's a very clear
idea here to open up the a file so his
rook can be activated
generally when a4 is played in the
rollopez b5 is not
a bad move to play as black just because
you want to keep the b file shut down
and so i think that's my top candidate
move
right now and if he takes then
that's actually just extremely bad for
his pawn structure
um my knight gets d4 and b4
and my bishop would get b4 so i'd
probably take on b4 with the bishop
have the d4 square for the knight
although i mean i could take with the
knight pressure this backwards d3 pawn
um i think actually that's probably a
little bit better a5 solidify the knight
in there so i think b4 is a pretty clear
move here
and neither of us will take he'll
probably play like knight bd2
did not know that yeah it's it's a
little misleading right a little
misleading because
i'm on the st louis chess club channel
so
most people
who stream on this channel live in st
louis they're streaming from st louis
not me
okay so we do see this
d4 move
and
let's
take a look here let's take a look
i also have to be worried about
like this tactic
and my bishop hangs
later takes
takes bishop b6
and i think that's okay
this pawn would be hanging knight
we could play a5
and castle
bishop
b6 whoa
i got uh i got startled
oh gory what's up man
if we drop it back
then takes
takes that's actually super okay like we
we actually want that
uh but the knights overworked
maybe we maybe we
didn't do this super well
so i think i think we made a mistake
because the knight
might be overworked here
oops
so we have to take
and
hopefully we're going to be okay
push them baby
all right
and now of course
we'll back up if we play bishop b6
then a5
maybe is annoying but we have knight
takes a5
so i think we're okay there
we reroute the knight to c5
but probably just bishop all the way
back to a7
is a little bit safer
allowing this bishop to be attacked by
the pawn like this i think is
unnecessary we want to play a5
anyway
a5 the bishop may return to b6 later
overall
we're definitely worse here
definitely worse you know we're worse
because
white has the massive
massive center it's very hard for us to
fight for the center upon it finally
thinking for a little bit
i think maybe i think maybe my opponent
was
not prepared to play a classical game
it can be very difficult to
focus keep your focus during online
classical game i think especially at the
high level here
so i'm not too surprised my opponent is
not using
a lot of their time hopefully we can
i mean i don't know
if they're playing well it doesn't
really matter if they're using their
time or not
they're still
they still have a better position than i
do
so i can't really say much
gene bands what's up man
okay so he does play a5
which i think is
a strong move because i wanted to play
a5
myself
however
i
do have the opportunity to win this
center pawn now
which actually looks
pretty valuable that looks like a very
very valuable center pawn
the other thing he could do is he could
sack here and then i play rook g8 he can
play bishop back to h4
i could
take this guy or i could even just play
rook to g4
and then threaten rook takes e4 so i
think sacking
probably doesn't work
so i think i'll go for this
win the pawn
i can escape the pin no problem
g5
bishop g3
takes and castles
i probably
take the bishop
he gives a check i can play knight e7
i'm gonna castle and play knight g6
kind of solidify and i have fantastic
bishops
sniping the board
so i think i'm gonna go for that
pushing baby
we'll see what you think
this might be a side effect of not using
his time i think it's a pretty
uh erroneous
mistake one thing that i think
really helps
improve your classical chess is actually
meditating
i think meditating can be
quite useful
for improving your focus
during the game
because all meditating is
is it's
it's just
thinking about nothing
that's all it is
and
just appreciating
life
appreciating
existence
and the current moment
so i think that practicing meditating
it's actually an interesting way to
improve your focus if you have trouble
focusing on
classical chess because that's really
all it is meditation is like
focus practice
it's kind of strange
i'm am i okay i'm yeah i'm totally fine
a kiwi fruit zero says i think white has
compensation for the pawn but i'm not
very good so what do i
know um
well i think maybe what that is is
i think white's position was better
before like a couple moves ago
and so
even when they lose the pawn
um
like black's position
black's biggest weakness in this
position is gonna be their long-term
king safety
right i'm probably gonna have to find
solace on the king side
and
it'll be
somewhat reminiscent of
king's gambit for black
i think i'll be okay
but
yeah i think this
center pawn is
it's a very critical pawn in white's
position it's
maybe even white's best pawn
in the position and so
you really don't want to lose that
i really don't want to lose that
so i'm very happy to get this pawn
he does have this move which is e5 which
is interesting
i wonder if he'll play it let's
calculate some variations
i was gonna say i don't think there's
much to think about in this position but
i actually don't know
what exactly i want to do if my opponent
does play this move e5 i'm kind of in
denial
actually i didn't see it before i played
g5
and i think it might actually be a
strong move for my opponent
so
e5
if they take
okay i can trade queens
the good thing about that is that
it totally opens up my bishops so my
bishops will be very very powerful if he
plays this move
but the downside is
this pawn may be very very weak
he's going to attack it with bishop g3
and
it might be really difficult for me to
defend it so e5
do i take or do i do something else
i could play knight g4
and then he'll obviously have to save
his bishop at that point
then i have the option of taking i
probably don't want to do that because
it opens up his rook file
so
e5 other option that i have is taking
his bishop
he'll take my knight
and then i can take the pawn
and i think that is
not bad
the main concern about that is
uh
my king safety right i would probably
have to castle queenside
which is actually not that bad
like my king has some weird type of
safety on this queen side so i think
that is probably the best way to go
if he plays e5
if he plays this move i'll take he'll
take
and then i'll take so still win a pawn
but it's very
it's a very unhealthy pawn because my
king side is shattered i'll very likely
lose back the h4 pawn
later in the game but once again
that doesn't change the fact that my
bishops are still very powerful
i'll be attacking this d4 pawn three
times so
he'll have to
i'll actually have to move it because he
can't defend it again so he'll he'll
probably play d5 if that happens
um
and in that case
i do have queen takes b2
but i think that would
that would actually win material
because
i thought at first that it lost material
because my opponent can play rook a2
um and my queen's attacked and my knight
still attacked
but actually now i'm not sure because i
thought after rook a2 i had queen takes
f2 checkmate but um
there's x-ray defense from the rook so i
would still have bishop takes f2 check
but um
that'd probably not be good because then
my queen and my bishop and my knight
would all be hanging
so maybe queen takes b2 doesn't actually
work there so once again the line is
e5
takes takes takes
d5
and then the other obvious move is just
95
which i think is not a bad move
and we'll go from there his bishop is
shut down
so is mine though
kind of
but this pawn on d5 could be a weakness
that we could
attack
potentially
maybe not even 95 maybe 97 just to
attack the d5 pawn again
also block the e file so there's no like
queen e2 check we're still hitting the
b2 spot so if he castles we'd have the
option of taking on b2 probably don't
want to because we actually we're
probably going to be castling queen side
so we don't really want to open up the b
file but yeah we would castle queen side
get our rooks on the e file
the f7 pawn would not hang because
the d5 pawn is blocking the bishop of
course so
no worries there
okay
so i think we know what we're gonna do
if our opponent plays e5 now which is
good you should calculate on your
opponent's time if
you can so yeah there was obviously a
lot that my opponent had to calculate
there
there was
sacking
there's bishop g3 there was e5 so
it's no surprise that they took a long
time there but i think here we just
nab the pawn and
be happy
that's why we played this move
wasn't it
so let's
let's go for it
he was definitely calculating the sack
that's an entire game that could have
played just thinking
that's true
it's kind of
surreal to think about like
when you're playing classical chess
sometimes you can
think more about a single position
than
like an entire
game
it's one of the beauties about classical
chess
right
so i don't think that move is a big
concern i think we just play
um
well i was going to say queen e7 but
we've actually we actually have a
a bigger move
which is knight takes d4
and the bishop is defended like that
however
knight takes knight takes bishop takes
and f3
is not super hot
it's not a very hot take
so i think first order of business is
unpinning and then maybe we can go for
this
so i think queen e2 is
probably
an inaccurate move
maybe
but we've got to start with queen e7
let's unpin
and i don't know we could actually we
could castle king side we could castle
queen side i think we can still go
either way at this point i don't think
one is
particularly safer than the other one at
this moment what are some possible moves
for my opponent
[ __ ] is a very obvious one he could
play
knight bd2 which is not a bad move
either
in that case
we'd probably take
and then he'd trade queens and then take
and then we'd win
a juicer
or sorry i forgot the knight actually
defends so
um
he could just take back with the knight
but then we would trade queens
and then we'd win
a juicer
we're not winning a pope
because the knight defends the pope what
if castling worked as well since if they
take the knight you can pin the queen
to the king so if i castle
kingside
if they take and i play rookie 8
then they have this move at least
they have 95 so they can sack the piece
back which is probably not something i
want to go into maybe it worked but i
don't know if i wanted to commit
castling kingside at this point
because here i still have the option of
castling queen side bringing this rook
to the e-file
and it's
gravy
i give myself an extra option which
could be very useful later in the game
did you know the pope technically is
also a bishop i think i did know that i
think i did know that
so you have to be
you have to be an archbishop
to become the pope
there's only like
300 archbishops in the world
right
set no no no i'm thinking of cardinals
you have to be a cardinal
to become the pope
there are only like 300 cardinals in the
world
and in order to become a cardinal
i think you have to be an archbishop
and in order to become an archbishop you
have to become a priest
so i think it goes priest
or or no wait is
is bishop below priest or above priest
in the catholic church hierarchy
it's above priests yeah so here here's
how it goes i think it this is how i'm
not looking at chat i think it goes
priest
bishop
archbishop
cardinal and then the pope
i'm pretty sure that is the hierarchy
archbishop just sounds cool
bishop is a bishop is above priest yeah
that's what i thought i think priest is
it's like the lowest level
uh well
where's deacon
is deacon deacons above priest
okay
let's look this up
catholic church
hierarchy
okay
pope cardinals archbishops bishops
priests deacons
the people
we were close we were close we just
didn't know where deacons were but i
think we got everything else correct
nice
okay
all right we've got a nice
castle gang here yo
castle gang what's up so
i really like this move for two reasons
the first is we get rid of our
opponent's bishop pair
and the second is it forces a queen
trade
which i'm going to be very happy with
because
uh my king is much less safe than his
so i think i certainly am going to play
this move
takes
he'll take all take
and then
he'll decide which way to take
and i think we get this juicer in the
end
is that correct
it might be a little bit sus
with this guy
but
we would also be checking him when we
capture with a bishop on d4
so we might have time to protect
this spot with like f6
something like that i think knight takes
g3 is going to be a good move here
let me just double check to make sure
i'm not blundering there's no reason to
be super speedy here takes
takes
takes
check
that move i can
i can go here i think
takes one thing i yeah and i think we're
good there
i think we're good
one thing i may be worried about is
taking with the f pawn
but i think we're okay
if he plays bishop takes f7 i can't take
with the king because then he'd play
knight takes d4 check discover check
with the rook
so instead i would play
knight takes f3 double check
um
and then i capture the bishop
and that would be good i'd win a piece
okay
i don't think it's a mistake
let's go for it
right i think taking with the knight is
just walking into
a weakness like this is a big weakness
and we want to keep pressuring this pawn
right so i think taking with the king
it's a pretty clear choice here we have
d7 and f6
which both spots could be potential safe
spots for our king i think d7
uh it's a little bit safer
and it's good because it guards the e8
square
but the downside is that it doesn't
defend the f7 pawn
and then f6 it's still pretty safe
not really anymore because the f file is
open but
it keeps the f7 pawn
guarded i think now is our opportunity
to
take this guy here if he checks us we
have
we have an opportunity for a discovered
check let's just go for this knight
takes d4
straight away i think this is good
i don't think this is a mistake
this guy's defended this guy's opened up
we're up
two pawns
the bishop has hit
so
you have to take this i think
you have to take it i'm i'm almost
certain you do
we'll take back of course
and now this guy's hit
so i think we play f6 and then our
bishop is in an outpost on e5
i think that is
not bad this spot is still hit
or we could play d5 but that blocks our
light squared bishop
so i don't know if i really like that
move
it's actually not
trivial yet but
we're definitely
getting there
this might be some idea although i'm a
little nervous about doing it because
the f5 pawn can be undermined
i don't have
this immediately because he throws in
the
check in between
which is not going to be great
so i think f6
is
really it's between f6 or d5
my one worry about f6 is that
he can eventually trade this bishop for
the knight
and then i think i'll have a weakness
i'll probably take with the f pawn but
then the b4 spot
is maybe a weakness and if i play c5
then
d6 becomes a weakness but i think i i
don't think it's actually that big of a
concern i can keep it very well defended
this a6 with white's light squared
bishop is
going to be a long term weakness for me
so i d like ideally i can get the light
squared bishops traded off
sooner than later
this is maybe a mistake
i'm curious to see if he'll sack this
pawn
i don't think it's a super bad idea yeah
i don't think it's a bad idea because
if he defends it he's just
much
much too passive right he needs to
try to get some sort of counter play
here
takes
so i don't hate the decision to sack the
pawn
but it is a free pawn so i'm gonna take
it
i think it's the swindler's choice right
he's he's in swindle territory right now
objectively it might be
a bad move
the conservative chess player would hate
that would hate uh knight d2
stockfish is a conservative chess player
but the swindler
plays knight d2 all day
knight d2 is the swindler's first choice
comes in for chess learns about
catholicism
hell yeah
we talk about a lot of different stuff
here
whoa
oh no
oh my goodness
well
good game to push him baby
very good game i can't say that
i am surprised at the
resignation
i think it's an early resignation
but uh good game good game to push and
baby let's take a look here
i want to take a look at this analysis
we played
wow
what look at this guys what can i say
we played fantastically
epic win
from a kiwi fruit thank you so much
thank you thank you e4 e5 knight f3 i
thought we were worse i honestly i won't
lie i thought we were worse in the
middle game
but uh
turns out we were okay bishop c5
it is a move here
i was agonizing over bishop e7 or bishop
c5
i think both are playable
well okay now we know that both are
playable
uh because we looked at the master
database but there there are advantages
to both
right
i went for bishop c5
bishop g5 and this was all good
the main advantage or sorry the main
downside to
putting your bishop here is that this
pin can be very annoying in some lines
which it it was
maybe slightly annoying but we broke it
with g5
bishop h4 you can see
masters have done the same here bishop
b7
a4 b4
keeping the a file closed very nice and
then d4
this was actually a mistake
e takes d4 c takes d4 bishop all the way
back to a7 and a5
right
it seems like maybe it's not a bad move
at first but
then you see that well it actually loses
a very very critical pawn on g5
after black plays g5
which is exactly what happened
and then queen e2
another
small mistake there queen e7
and
castles unfortunately just allows me to
simplify into a very winning endgame
f692 bishop takes b2
all right very good game pushing baby
very nice that was only an hour that was
actually
quite a short classical game